[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to filming to
prep
independent presents our year-round
screening and q
a series now virtual uh thank you for
joining us
um first off i'd like to thank our loyal
supporters
our lead sponsor the hollywood foreign
press association
our screening partner vision media and
our media partner
los angeles times thank you so much for
joining us
to chat all about amazon prime videos
one
night in miami with writer kim powers
and director regina king and today we
have a very special guest moderator one
of our favorites carla renata aka
the curvy critic if you have a question
for our panelists uh please use the q
a button at the bottom of your screen
and hopefully we can get to it towards
the end of our session
uh in the meantime without further ado i
will let carla take it from here
thank you brian welcome kemp and regina
is so wonderful to see y'all today
great to see you too great to be here
yes okay let's get
right on into it i'm gonna start with
kim
kim my hu bison brother
you have taken this prolific play
and adapted it into a screenplay for the
screen directed by my beautiful sister
regina king
how exciting has this journey been for
you
oh it's been a dream i mean honestly
you know when i first wrote the play i i
was just talking to someone earlier
today about
on opening night of the play in a 99
seat theater in los angeles
saying to myself saying out loud oh man
i could die happy today
i was able to bring this story to an
audience and that audience was like 99
people
in a theater on pico boulevard next to
roscoe's
and i had never in a million years
thought that the story would connect so
well
and and keep on moving on and that i'd
be even allowed to be a part of the
process this long
so this is uh this is it's really been
surreal
um and you know working in theater
working in hollywood
it's it's it's rare to to find
collaborators
um you know who are as open and
thoughtful and giving
as as regina is i mean i'd heard so many
things about regina before i met her
and i i really like you know usually
when you meet someone
and you're like oh wow they're
everything people said they were
and regina is a unique person in that
she's like so far more
than all the wonderful things that you
hear about regina honestly
don't measure up to like who she had who
she is
as a person who she is as a human being
so this collaboration
for me was also kind of like a
mentorship
um in terms of understanding things
about you know
filmmaking and cinema and how this
business works so this has really been a
surreal almost like dream experience for
me
and i'm sure it's been an even more
surreal dream experience for you because
brother you got two major features
happening
while we are in a pandemic so claps and
snaps for you on that
i had nothing to do with that i'm just
you know what i'm happy they got
finished that's the truth i'm happy
and miss regina you are just you're like
a tornado that we watch touch the ground
and the beauty that that nature of the
force of nature brings is what you are
to the
hollywood industry and we're so happy
that you exist and that you're here
and that you took on one night in miami
as your directorial
debut right but i want to talk about
your directorial process
i remember a while ago when i was doing
a uh
internet radio show over at sunset gower
studios i would see you quite often
coming to visit debbie allen
and so i'm wondering how instrumental
has she been
to helping you thrive in this new lane
of directing
well i mean if you were seeing me on
sunset gower i
might have been visiting shonda no i saw
you
i saw you with debbie one day when i was
i was directing an episode of scandal
and debbie came to just
you know just give me that sisterly
director you got this
love you know and she she didn't have to
do that
but it's funny though when you ask about
how influential debbie has been i think
a lot of
directors uh especially directors who
were in the industry in another capacity
before we became directors how much she
has
inspired us and inspired us because
she's been doing it
so well and doing it um
uh with so much energy
you know and and with so much uh
love actually and so um
to to have that moment it's so funny
that you
brought that up because i haven't
thought about it in a while
um yeah i i totally remember
we had just finished like our table read
for the uh
episode i was directing and i was coming
out
and boom and debbie was right there she
was like girl i was looking for you
and she just you know went and if you
have any questions if you
anything you know don't hesitate to call
me and
you know they're going to be moments
where you just may feel unsure but just
you got this just breathe through it and
just rely on
all of the uh things that you've picked
up along the way
you may not have employed these skills
but they're already there they're within
you
and um she just reminded me just you
know my journey as an actor
uh was educating me all the while
for for you know that moment and
um yeah so debbie debbie has been an
influence and inspiration i'm glad to
hear that she's most def
she she like yourself is definitely a
force to be reckoned with in the
entertainment industry for sure for sure
i want to talk a little bit about you
all's collaboration with your dp
and your editors to bring this to the
screen because it all takes place
virtually
well for the most part in that one room
and that can be a little challenging
editing wise and um uh filming it
so can we just speak to how you
collaborated with uh
tammy and tarek on working that together
how to get angles which things worked
which things
didn't which things were like uh i don't
know
well i mean for me it started with a
an amazing script you know just the the
ev the
the blueprint was there uh the dialogue
was the star
and it remained that for
all of us um from from the first moment
each of us
had read uh kemp's work and
so you really uh
for me it was
it started from what the relationship
was gonna be
like between kemp and i you know my
my hope was that we would connect
immediately
and we did we did and we were in two
different cities and kim was kemp was
back and forth between oakland and la
working on seoul and i was back and
forth between atlanta
and everywhere working on
um watchmen so we we both had other
projects that we were working on but
the passion that camp had when he had
written
um uh one night was
very clear to me and then meeting him
it was um
even more clear that
he uh understood the importance
of telling a story that reflected the
men
that uh we know that we know
personally that reflected him that
reflected
my my son my you know what i mean that
was a
a reflection of all the wonderful things
that
make um them who they are
um and when that's wonderful easy though
did i with those 12
those 12-page dialogue scenes well yeah
yeah i think that means a long way of
coming to that
i got to set it up because eddie i was
just about to say because
editing that you don't want to miss
anything you don't want to cut anything
out because everything that's being said
is so incredibly important powerful to
the moment you know yes
yes absolutely so with with that
kemp opened the film uh opened the play
up when he uh uh adapted it by
opening the film up and making the
decision
to humanize these men in a way
that um
we immediately take the
name off of them we take cassius malcolm
jim sam you immediately after
these uh moments of of of meeting each
of them
in their own world in their own
uh space we immediately go
oh i know what that feels like oh
i've been there wow even or
or either wow even they had to deal with
it so it immediately makes you go
all right i'm settling into this and and
i'm i
am investing in this
very human moment that takes place
between the four of them
so well with that uh we've already
we've kind of let things air out in the
beginning
so that when we're about to be in that
room for the amount of time that we are
in the room um we've invested
so we just as uh
in production we actually
shot long takes you know we're doing all
um 12 pages in a take
and and that was heavy lifting that was
a lot on the actors but
when we started the process i told them
you got to know this script like a play
even though that we're shooting it you
got to know it like a play
we don't have the money we don't have
the time we don't have the rehearsal
time
and and they
felt as i did that the dialogue is the
star and if we lose
any bit and and it's they're they're the
ones that
transport us you know and make you
receive that dialogue
and and they understood that they
understood
the magnitude of that so a lot of that
lifting was there
in the actors uh uh what they were doing
in a frame
and and for us is uh tammy and i
um i told her that i really wanted to
make sure there was movement
in the in in the frame even
if we're not moving but i don't want the
camera to be distracting
so we shot on the jib arms whenever we
were inside the room
and when we went up on the roof um
i always known that i wanted it to be a
handheld just
reading the scene with the fumble of the
camera i was like
oh yeah this is gotta feel you know uh
energetic uh uh uh with the
um the visuals so
uh and tarek was just
gosh i don't know kim taric is just he
just was
a hero he he he
even moments when i would feel like oh
my god did i get everything
he was always like if you didn't get
something i will call you regina
but i would still call him to ask him
did i get everything
and any um we had um
this uh as as most people know
that are that are in this audience with
with film
storytelling you know you sometimes uh
scenes will um change
that they won't keep the same order in
which they were written
and because kemp while he is precious
about the story
um was not uh so precious
with the scene order that he
was willing to sacrifice
you know the best story that we can tell
and um
uh i think because we stayed in
communication throughout the whole time
kemp was able to
come to set when he was he moonlighted
on one night in miami while he was
directing uh seoul yeah yeah
uh but i just think that communication
and keeping when i would have an idea to
do something
slightly different sharing it with him
and
um if there was a anything that made him
feel like
yeah i think that's good but you know
just be mindful of this
you know we we honored that and you know
we were able to have that
that open dialogue that as kim said it
was collaboration it never
felt like um at least for me it never
felt like
an imposition and i hope it never felt
like that for him
i'm just i'm i'm a screenwriter i'm used
to not even being invited on set
so for me i'm just like wait why are you
calling me you want my opinion it's a
very screenwriting can be a very
you know you feel like you're at the
bottom of the totem pole so this
experience was um
was uh really you know uh a joy
it really was well brother you are
definitely not at the bottom of the
totem pole with two films
in theaters and streaming at the same
time let's just put that out there
and let's talk about the fact that you
know this went up in 2011 as a play
right and now
2013. and now we're in 2020
the play is dealing with the same issues
that we're dealing with right now
right civil rights past present and
possibly
in the future did you think
that in 2020 that one night in miami was
still going to resonate with that
black lives matter resonance that it
does
today i mean unfortunately yes i did
think it was going to resonate because
we've been having this discussion for a
long since before
this night you know this is this has
been a discussion that goes back to
w.e.b du bois and booker t washington
and what i mean
what is the best way forward for black
people
in this country that um
in many ways just refuses to acknowledge
and accept our humanity
you know and for black creatives um
you know it's it's something that i
think you think about
all the time which is what if any social
responsibilities do i have as a black
artist
um i'm i'm of the mind that like
you often hear things like i just want
to be seen as a
director an actor a writer not a black
director writer actor
and that's that's something i used to
say a lot in my 20s nowadays
i want to be seen as a black writer
because the reality is i think that the
black
experience contains all the multitudes
of experience it can be black and it can
be everything it can be science fiction
it can be comedy
it can be western i think that the black
experience is the human experience
and it's not something that needs to be
seen as a
as a negative i know the the big
difference between now and 2013
for me honestly is just that
it's a discussion that people are having
more publicly you know
um the play when the play came out it
was very challenging to get people to
produce the play
what i would often hear was that there
was a concern that
the unapologetic blackness of the play
would alienate
white theater goers wow now the
difference between now and then is that
i guess unapologetic blackness is kind
of in right now
or i should at least say white people
are into it white people love
unapologetic blackness right now
i hope that artists and creatives
continue being unapologetic about their
art
even when white people aren't into it
anymore because it'll come again it's
just
it's not a fad we are who we are um
and i look forward to the day when this
film is just a time capsule
i i mean that's that's that's the dream
right
that's the dream when it's something
that's of a time and it can just
stay in that time and doesn't feel like
it resonates but
the answer is like i did not write this
in reaction to
anything that was happening it's all
coincidence in 2013 trayvon martin
happened
that was a coincidence the play was
already up and running when george
zimmerman got off
in 2015 when it ran in baltimore freddie
gray happened
you know it's like every time the play
was getting produced
there was someone getting shot or killed
i mean it was just it was so constant
that you lost
track of the names and i'm really
looking forward to the part the time
when it's just
a moment in history a second that
emotion for sure for sure
i'm gonna flip over to the questions
because we have both of you here and you
you are such wealths of knowledge both
of you in terms of the film and the
subject matter
encapsulated in the film that i'm just
gonna go straight to the questions
because there's like a zillion of them
um regina i know you have a lengthy
background in directing television but
for your first feature film
were you looking for a small scale film
like this finding a story set mostly in
one room
or did the limited setting present any
foreseen unforeseen challenges
that's from matt brown well i wasn't uh
looking for a particular type of first
family
you know i i was in conversations with
my agent
about the stories that i wanted to tell
as a director in the film
and uh one of those things that i wanted
to do was i wanted to
uh tell a love story
uh with an historic backdrop like a
titanic
you know but with the couple being black
and um
he heard me when i said that and one
night in miami came along while it
wasn't a romantic love story
it is in fact a love story in in
it it is love is part of the story uh um
uh and so uh and it was
uh uh the the bass they did have an
historical backdrop you know cassius
clay becoming
the heavyweight champion of the world so
um that that
was one of the
list of of stories that i would like to
tell i feel like i can
kind of almost check that one off um
but i think more than anything
for me once i did read one night in
miami
was one of the things that stood out was
that this was an
actor's piece and um
you know that might be a strength of
mine you know depending on who you ask
uh but i knew that again
going back to the dialogue being the
star
the right actors would understand that
and just
embody these men opposed to
doing a characterization of these men
because let's face it we've seen
um uh muhammad ali and malcolm x
portrayed very well and we've seen them
portrayed poorly
and this was um um
gonna be a moment of seeing them again
but in a very specific way in a way in
my opinion we had never seen or explored
uh when we're uh looking at uh
uh or telling stories that involve those
two men and then jim brown and sam cook
were icons as well and um
here we have them all together
you know when i go back and look at it
right now and i think about
the fact that kemp decided to write this
and that
you know i decided to direct this and
anyone that came on board
decided to be a part of it i think it's
pretty
gutsy you know you're talking about
cassius clay
jim brown sam cook no x
yes those each one of them in their
own way during that time during their
time
was polarizing in their own way
you know some of them a little more or
less than others but all four of them
were like they were the creme de la
creme of the black community
at the time yeah and and powerful
powerful men you know anyone
that you ask about those men that that's
one
uh descriptive word that you would use
for all four of them in kemp's piece
it was the vulnerability that
made them powerful that makes all of us
power you know vulnerability is strength
and um so yeah
i answered your question yes girl you
answered it and then some
let's talk about this casting process
you guys cast
four really great great actors you cast
aldous hodge leslie odom jr
kingsley ben adair and eli
what was your process in having these
actors who were so
wonderful and specific in their own ways
what was your casting process
in getting those four men together the
right configuration of those four men
well it was quite the casting process
you know kemp was there throughout
the entire process um we
saw a lot of people um we uh
we it's you know this oh gosh there's
so many um different
um thoughts that were had as we were
uh coming along and and figuring it out
when we didn't have anyone and then
aldis was the first person that we cast
and he um we did not get to see him in
person
he put himself on tape i had a
conversation with him gave him some
notes
and he put himself on tape again he was
in australia shooting a film i think it
was
shooting invisible man if i'm not
mistaken
and um uh
so having houses kind of became the
anchor which is really interesting
because jim
is the anchor and the phone speaker of
the film
so it became kind of casting
with aldis as that anchor and
um uh so
while some things are oh
just a actor just may have obviously
just
given the best performance hands down
uh with uh uh um an audition
i think specifically uh after
aldus um there were just certain things
that each of them did
that made it clear that um
they understood uh the journey ahead
um from uh uh from a from an artist
standpoint
and from a responsibility standpoint
again because they were gonna be playing
these four men
who are real people these are they're
real people they're not just characters
these are people
living breathing human beings that had
lives and careers and families and
families exactly yeah um so thank you
regina for answering that
kim tyson tarot wants to know one of the
things i loved in both the play and the
feature
was how well developed the characters
were
nobody could say those lines except for
specific characters saying them how much
research
did you have to go through before you
knew that you could write
as each one of them and get into their
character
uh years um it was years honestly when i
first found out that that night really
happened because the night did happen
the dialogue in the
situation is fictional but that's
february 25th 1964
cassius was at the hampton house in
malcolm's room with sam and jim eating
vanilla ice cream
and the next morning is when he said i'm
in the nation of islam
call me sex that's all real um but when
i first found out about it
i started researching it with the
intention of writing a book about their
friendship
because i was still uh when i first
found out about this real night i was
still a journalist
so you know playwriting and
screenwriting is my second career
so this was like 10 11 years ago and i
was like oh i'm gonna write a book
about the friendship between these four
unapologetically black men
who were so unapologetic during such
this dangerous time and their friendship
really blossomed during like a
three-year period
between like late 1962 and
early 1965 so it was like really a an
incredible
look at what would become to me
inspiration for like a nascent black
power movement
so i had years worth of research
and then when i decided to write it as a
work of fiction
i i saw it as a responsibility to make
sure that i characterized each of these
guys in a realistic way
like regina was saying i wanted to focus
on their humanity
i wanted to focus on their vulnerability
but
often when you hear like a film and
humanizing someone
it usually just means make them do
something bad you know what i mean like
let's
let's see this famous person behaving so
outside of
you know who they were but i think that
we all have both the public and
private version of ourselves you know
and while our private version of
ourselves
might not seem that dramatically
different to us it is dramatic to the
public
so you know it was really key it's like
i wouldn't have malcolm x
come into the room with strippers you
know what i mean like that just
you know and that's what i was really
challenging myself to do i wanted to
to be perfectly honest as arrogant as it
might sound
i wanted to challenge myself to write
characterizations of each of these four
men
that was so on point that even people
who knew them
would believe that they would say and do
all the things that they said and did in
the film
it was impressive because like regina
said at the beginning
when she answered one of the first
questions i asked these men are people
we know
these are our fathers our grandfathers
our uncles our cousins
our sons our nephews we know who these
men
are so you did that perfectly it was
right on point my brother thank you like
if you're having a party right
and like let's say you're gonna have a
party and you got these four guys there
you know which one's going to be the
buzz kill it's going to be malcolm
you know what i mean so you just fit
them into any group of us gets together
and we kind of fall into roles and i
just wanted to put each of these guys
into their
correct role in the same role that it
would be if it was
just me and my boys you know and treat
them like that like they were just being
like a bunch of boys
this is one of the things i love about
your writing because you did the same
thing with seoul we talked
um when we were doing the soul junking
about the whole barbershop scene you
always find a way to bring the culture
right as it is
in that moment to your work and i for
one wholeheartedly appreciate it and i
understand it
and i'm so glad that you're out there
doing it and and
bringing it to the masses so that they
can understand it and see it and enjoy
it too so thank you so much kemp
appreciate that i really i mean that
from the bottom of my heart
seriously um let's talk about some
lighting and sound design
jonathan says he loved the lighting and
the overall look of the film
gorgeous cinematography did any other
films help inform or inspire the
aesthetic design of one night in miami
well i'm glad you enjoyed it jonathan um
yeah a few um barry's
bill street could talk i could say that
now
uh absolutely and
uh in the move for love uh those two
films
probably uh inspired uh
the look uh the most and then
um jacob lawrence as an artist
his paintings and uh just
for us the the for tammy uh
a production designer uh barry and um
my wardrobe designer uh francine uh
jameson that this
jacob lawrence's work especially this
one painting
that we was our go back to all the time
was our color palette
and and we stayed in that color palette
so each one of our men even because i
think sam has like five
six changes throughout the entire film
um you'll see them
in that color palette if you go to
any set um whether it's uh
the coppa or if it's
fountain blue um
if that is within that color palette and
um
you know we we went as far as the
paneling
on the in the room of the hampton house
that we brought each one of the actors
to set
up against four or five different panels
uh
to determine which color which grain we
were going to go with
because they were going to be in there
for so long and it needed to be
complementary to all of their
complexions
because that's kind of also the beauty
of black people that
all of them are in all different colors
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
and i can i add on just i know it's
going back to an early question about
casting
that was one of the things i thought was
so awesome is that you know
regina didn't just she cast the the core
four based on one another so that
you know when you see them as a group
they matched up
really really well to one another in
terms of
age appearance down height everything
like you really kind of just looking at
the four of them standing against the
wall
believe them before they open their
mouths
in the in the the role that they would
have to play and that was something that
really struck me i don't even think
regina knows this
but in almost every casting of the stage
play
the first person usually cast is jim
brown
really no that's actually for every
production that's always been the anchor
around which everyone else gets cast
it's always jim brown first
look at that great minds think alike
wow that's that's really that's some
special and
it is right thank you for sharing that
kim
no i'll get to say that and then all
right
rest of your jungles you can say so kemp
said
i love that let's flip over to the sound
design real quick um
tyson terrell again says i found it very
intimate the sound design especially
during the boxing scene
which is very different from what is
traditional for boxing scenes
all also not much music that i noticed
until the near end of the second act
what were your thoughts
as you created the soundscape thank you
so much
well um they're there there there is
he's correct
uh tyson um that
that there is not a lot of music
but again i with dialogue this powerful
i'm really not a fan of music stepping
on dialogue
um it rubs me kind of
uneasy as an audience member so
definitely i wouldn't be making that
choice as a director
with with this uh piece especially
but um part of it is also pandemic
related
um when it came down to doing the score
we i we we didn't have that that
wonderful
opportunity that you normally have where
you get to sit
with your composer and have these great
conversations
and then go into the studio and and
you know figure it out with artists that
was not an
option um for us and
uh so uh along the way
we just kind of made the discovery that
um
let's let piano be a fifth character
let's let's let the because there were
this when i kind of put my playlist
together
um and only one song is actually in the
film
but for when it comes to
uh film i feel like probably a lot of
directors
can relate to and writers as well can
relate to
you have just certain songs or sounds
that are inspiring that feel like they
connect
to the story and for me donnie hathaway
and nina simone
uh just her arrangement the bluesiness
that nina has um and
and a few other blues songs were part of
my playlist that i put together in one
night in miami and one of the thing that
was very common
in that playlist is the piano you know
and so uh we we made a decision
to uh go uh with the
pretty much piano score throughout
except for
um there's one prayer scene where we
again it's a solo
uh instrument with we use the duke and
um uh and benny green
flew in from uh uh northern california
and recorded all of those uh piano uh
moments that
take us from the first fight in uh
um in uh london
to uh the coppa and from the
fight from uh miami
to say sam pulling up you know so
there are uh the music does become a bit
of a
character so much so that you know i
guess
maybe some may have missed it in places
that's hilarious you're like well maybe
um
i want to ask this question i tried to
get to let me just say this i tried to
get to everyone's questions and some of
them were very similar
and or regina and kemp answered them so
if i didn't call your name out or call
the
question out in particular it's because
they had already answered it i'm not
dissing y'all i'm just trying to
expedite the process so
having said that um there is a question
about
what involvement if any did jim brown
and the estates of muhammad ali
malcolm x and sam cook have with the
film
well jim brown's daughter is actually
in the film so that answered that
yes um i had
conversations with um
uh may may ali leila ali and also
ambassador shabazz
um and uh just
because i knew all of those women prior
to
doing the film i just kind of wanted to
let them know that i was doing this and
that would be great to have their
blessing
and i understand just their their
fathers being who
their fathers are and and how much they
mean to
them let alone the rest of the world
um i understand if they had any
you know thoughts or feelings going in
um but
maymay and layla had actually seen the
play so they were
aware of you know the story that we were
telling
and and all of them had given me their
blessing and all of them
uh didn't uh try to
they shared their honest feelings about
um how dear their fathers are
to them and you know i assure them that
my intention is not to do anything
uh uh other than
uh pay respect to the men that they are
and um my conversations with ambassador
shabazz
you know her being the eldest of um
malcolm's children uh she definitely
shared a couple little anecdotes that um
we ended up infusing yeah we wrote them
as soon as regina told me i'm like
i'm writing that right into the movie
yeah
and he was like she did say it was okay
i was like yup
this is the perfect example how much
kemp and i would be on the same page
so i'm having the conversation with
ambassador shabazz and she's
sharing this and i'm like oh my god
because it's a moment that i'm like
we forget that malcolm's a father a a
a husband and and kemp has already
uh given us more
um than than i think we've
seen before as far as just
the the man that's not the great orator
that's not the great
um motivator um
and so what um ambassador
shared with us was just an extension of
that
and and so i immediately was like
i better ask her is she okay with this
and
i said do you think can i can include
this
in the film how would you feel she was
like sure sure
i i just i she said i hate to watch
films that people have access to the
people
that um were part of those lives
and they don't talk to them
and um i uh thought that
you know that was really interesting
because i think a lot of films
probably people do want to talk to the
people but uh
it financially it doesn't really work
out
if they can and she was
a person that wasn't looking for money
she just
um was um speaking to
uh um the last time i'd seen her i was
16 years old
and and last time i'd spoken to her 16
years old so she was just
blessing this 16 year old girl that she
that now is a woman that she was proud
of and and
was just sharing so and for those who
don't know the scene it's
when malcolm calls his daughter that's
ambassador shabazz
he did leave notes for her hidden in
books so
we we i wrote that's that moment because
it was something that she told us about
wow you guys have dropped so many little
kernels of nuggets and some
information that i certainly didn't know
going into the film or having seen it as
i told regina
right before we went live that i've seen
the movie five times and i'll probably
see it again
but um unfortunately we have to end it
right now
regina king you are the bomb.com and i'm
speaking it into existence this film
is gonna get all kinds of love this
awards season and i am there for all of
it
kemp powers these two films that you
have
seoul and one night in miami honoring us
brother thank you from your howard
university
bison sister thank you from the bottom
of my heart and thank both of you for
joining us today for this film
independent discussion
on one night in miami i am your
moderator
carla renata aka the curvy critic and i
will
see y'all next time bye regina and kim